heaven what's your message of the day if
you love your wife because she's special
and for a famous French Museum then
we're going to Notre Dame then we're
going to the pantheon
and let's see if we get all that in one
day let's go why so famous that why
everyone has to go see it Mona Lisa yeah
I don't know okay I
am relaxing
good to explain the last two hours you
get to explain what happened
[Music]
good morning so last night what happened
we got back we just chilled because I
was not feeling so well I just lying
down and chill and then uh but still try
to sleep and could not sleep but until
Evan why don't you just put something on
to watch and then finally pass out
around like just after one something
local time and uh now we're up before
eight o'clock because we have places to
go
and never did not sleep well
he's a tire guy I told her just take it
easy today gonna take it easy today we
got stuff to do lives change and and
my wife is beautiful you're gonna you're
gonna you take it easy today I'm gonna
do what we do the karmic away yeah he's
not gonna he's not gonna we're ready to
go but maybe I'll just I'm not feeling
so avoid them we just take it easy then
he will do it anyway we're gonna um pick
up some breakfast and go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
looks nice huh the flowers who are we
heading to Evan we're going
to pick up our pass yep then we're going
to the Louvre
famous fence Museum then we're going to
Notre Dame then we're going to the
pantheon
and let's see if we get all that in one
day let's go
[Music]
Evan what's your message of the day
to love your wife because she's special
is that a good message sure it's a great
one come on it's a great one
all right well did you just pick up Evan
we picked up our
our pass to museum pass so we have a six
day
to pass
not all the museums okay and we have
another pass for attractions okay so one
pass for museums and one pass for
attractions the last six days okay
now we'll go to the first Museum Blue
Room let's go
okay guys let me tell you if you ever
have to travel with Evan Carmichael you
need to keep up with them imagine if I
had some sleep last night yeah yeah I
had to run to catch up to him it's a
good thing you have long legs no I have
very short legs
foreign
thank you
thank you
[Music]
Okay evan
what are we doing
we're going through the Louver oh wait
hold on so we went to take a picture and
then of the Mona Lisa you took a picture
with a momentum book on it that's true
yeah why so famous why everyone has to
go see it Mona Lisa yeah I don't know I
don't know the story oh let me I told
you the story oh what's the story though
who's the guy who drew the Mona Lisa
DaVinci Da Vinci yeah because he painted
so well
it looks like he knows the sculpture
Under the Skin like it was really good
that people need to go see it
how's Napoleon who's Napoleon yeah
French Emperor okay one of the most
powerful people in human history okay
and we're gonna go visit his Apartments
see how he lived
[Music]
foreign
building up and this is it I hope
[Music]
[Applause]
how we doing Evan
we're doing how are you doing tired a
little tired yeah yeah doing yeah we're
going next we're going to ancient Greek
Greece and Rome ancient Greece and Rome
and France in France yeah in France yeah
[Music]
we're done with the Egypt yeah you like
it oh it's okay different yeah it's not
my thing as much as get the greasy rum
so let's okay
[Music]
all right we have arrived in Greece
[Music]
how was it pretty good okay but then
give a little bit more information what
do you think why did you put it on you
you could tell people you could tell
everybody
um it's good I do like history but I
won't spend that much time and to look
at each little thing we did the entire
Louvre in under two hours yeah finish
another two hours so
we did two floors yeah I appreciate
people who love art I don't understand
art you know there's some nice things we
like something we don't have to see all
of it we saw the major things yeah and
now we're gonna get well get a coffee
get a break you hungry yeah I need a
break okay great okay Reagan and then
not to them not Hotel Church
foreign
and
just sitting down which is nice Nina
wants to sit down
how's your coffee and then everything
else
uh good we're relaxed we're both kind of
feeling the tiredness I'm not sleeping
I had four hours Nina had six hours
but anyway
um yeah let's get the break sit down had
a had a croissant and a coffee and now
we're gonna head to Notre Dame and we
had more planned but uh we'll see we'll
see how we do we'll see how the wipe
holds up if she's getting tired we gotta
go
you guys a happy wife is a happy
anniversary and a happy life let's go
[Music]
so this is the Natural Dam event
Notre Dame uh it is under construction
because of the fire two years ago
two or three years ago
oh okay well a lot of time
[Music]
are you sad and it's burned down
yeah it's uh
very historic building they're doing
their I mean it's why it's taking so
long to fix it they're going really inch
by inch to make sure they're doing a
good job so it's too bad we can't go
inside but uh that's okay they're doing
their thing we're gonna go to uh I
haven't been to this church same island
this is a little tiny Island and this is
a famous interior stained glass windows
so let's check it out it's close
[Music]
stained glass we finished it yeah it was
good it's nice yeah it's like a little
little chapel very nice very quick yeah
yeah beautiful okay
next up next stop well okay we have a we
can go to the pantheon okay but it's an
18 minute walk okay can we bust it I
don't think so
it's across the river oh there's no bus
you want to Uber no
next stop Pantheon okay while we're
going to Pantheon uh I've never been
inside
it's uh I don't really know the history
it's a nice looking building
we're in the area we have a little more
time and we have the museum pass so
we'll uh go outside it's a 15 minute
walk from here and we'll go inside
with us it's windy here
[Music]
I've been struggling a little bit
sniffling in a lot it's okay yeah
okay we're gonna wait for our Uber and
head back to the hotel
we're ready relax a little bit yeah we
earned it
[Music]
okay I had a relaxing you get to explain
the last two hours you get to explain
what happened you get that what did you
do you were you know we came up and she
was starving like I need to eat right
now I'm getting angry no no I didn't no
I didn't say I would need to eat right I
was very hungry and then I just chill I
just I just I just like okay let me open
for two hours let me just have some
water because I was so tired I didn't
want to move goodness I just give you
some waters I'll just have some water
and then and then there's like okay let
me just jump so tiny I need to chill so
just spend two hours on my phone doing
nothing
I was booking tickets yeah we have our
tickets booked for tomorrow for Dijon
the ones we wanted were sold out so we
have a different ticket so we get there
a little later which isn't great but at
least we have our tickets booked yeah uh
figured out how to get to Versailles
anyway we've got some good planning done
okay now we're gonna go have some sushi
dinner it's a little bit healthier than
what we've been having so let's go let's
find the address
[Music]
okay
Sushi sandwich
awesome good job for finding the
restaurant
do you like the dinner it's good yeah
that was good I liked it it was good
okay
um it's good but the rice is very wet
it's a little soggy than I expected I
liked it okay anyways good pick who's
the expert on Asian food come on I am
okay we're gonna go back to the hotel
relax more and prepare for a long day
tomorrow not really no we have to take
the train in true yeah Dijon we're going
to Dijon we're going to meet movement
makers Alberto we're gonna try some
Dijon mustard
okay and then and uh surprise Adventures
so if you want to see what we do
tomorrow yeah check it out right there
next to us I think you'll enjoy it
to believe and we'll see you there